did that guy pay
I'm off the grid for August but fear not
CNN is still a far left activist
organization pretending to be a
journalistic outfit
Richard Greenberg walked into a San
Francisco Walgreens when he saw in the
frozen food section this change heavy
chains that went from padlock to padlock
on both sides of the doors and this was
bizarre something I'd never seen before
this is just
icing on the cake
that rampant
a regular part of life so typical that
in the 30 minutes we were at this
Walgreens
we watched three people including this
man
did that guy pay
he didn't pay
Walgreens says this Richmond
neighborhood store with aisles of
products like mustard locked behind
Plexiglas has the highest theft rate of
all their nearly 9 000 Us stores hit
more than a dozen times a day when
thieves turn to cleaning out ice cream
and frozen burritos workers grew so
frustrated they resorted to the chains
they were ordered down by corporate
because of the negative messaging
but Walgreens isn't the only retailer
impacted in San Francisco
have to ask an employee for help at this
store frozen food is controlled with a
cable lock fake eyelashes locked behind
Plexiglas along with lotion and nail
polish
at another grocery store 14 bags of
coffee under lock and key what is this
um I don't know I don't understand why
coffee oh here she is
it's become kind of like a police state
in San Francisco I don't know how to
describe it it's not part of city life
it's not part of the way people should
be living right and that includes folks
who are committing the crimes Marjan
fill our mom of three small business and
Community Advocate says these visible
problems in her City are leading to
renewed activism driven by residents
like the recall of the city's district
attorney last year I think what we've
seen especially in the past couple of
years is
less tolerance more exasperation and
more movement to action by everyday San
franciscans to change how their city is
run it's not enough right now but there
is a change and I think ultimately we
will get there San Francisco city
supervisor Matt Dorsey former police
spokesman and recovering drug addict
sees the rampant shoplifting as a
systemic problem from city leaders to an
understaffed police force to the
fentanyl crisis when you're seeing that
level of retail theft that tends to be
subsistence level retail theft people
who are hungry people are hungry there
is a level of addiction playing out in
many parts of our city it's happening at
levels we really haven't seen in San
Francisco what I'm hearing from my
residents and what I'm hearing from San
franciscans is it's time for tough love
we are not doing any addict in this city
favors by enabling behavior that is
potentially deadly in ways we have never
seen
Ellen a statement to CNN Walgreens says
it is focused on safety and preventative
measures but that retail theft remains
one of its top challenges here's some
important contexts though on the city
Aaron property crime and violent crime
at the end of last year was actually
lower than it was before the pandemic so
what's going on here low-level drug use
as well as the sort of retail theft may
be considered lower level crimes but
they're uniformly and widely felt by so
many
foreign